chevet du pâté de route ils sont
désormais les ambassadeurs et les
défenseurs de produits qui ont failli
disparaître la poule et le pâté de
houdan depuis 2016 une soixantaine
d'adhérents sont partis de cette
confrérie qui organisait son quatrième
chapitre il s'agit d'une réunion
annuelle la communauté intronise de
nouvelles personnes au cours d'une
cérémonie bien particulière on a une
épreuve c'est de manger le pâté on boit
un petit verre de vin blanc pour pour le
faire passer également et ensuite eh
bien on jure sur un serment comme quoi
on devient des ambassadeurs de cette
confrérie où on va dire une bande d'amis
ils se réunissent régulièrement pour
organiser ce genre de réception
trente et une personnes ont été
intronisées certaines viennent d'autres
confréries gastronomiques d'autres sont
des personnalités toutes ont à coeur de
défendre ce mets de choix qui était
notamment servi sur la table de louis
xiv
c'est vrai que le paquet de houdan c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est vraiment
une tradition locale et je pense que ça
doit se défendre parce que chaque région
doit défendre son patrimoine et
patrimoine gastronomique c'est aussi
quelque chose de très important
ce quatrième chapitre s'est terminée par
un défilé en ville
[Musique]
ça fait revivre un peu le centre de
houdan qui se meurt donc ça fait du bien
on voit que les traditions sont
perpétuées qu' il ya encore du monde qui
s'intéresse au patrimoine et au terroir
français et c'est assez important de
préserver sa aujourd'hui très
prochainement le pâté de houdan figurera
sur la carte de grands palaces parisiens
[Musique]